[Aplausos]
[Música]
y tal es conocida como el enfermo de
europa junto a grecia es el único país
de la eurozona que es más pobre hoy en
día que hace 20 años habéis oído bien se
estima que cada ciudadano italiano ha
perdido una media de 73 mil euros desde
el año 1999 todo esto es sorprendente si
tenemos en cuenta que en los años 90
italia era la locomotora europea fijaos
en esta gráfica
[Música]
en el año 1992 los italianos llegarán a
ser más ricos incluso que los británicos
estos eran los años donde milán era la
capital indiscutible de la moda los
coches fiab dominaban los mercados y
cantantes como laura pausini o eros
ramazzotti lloraban estadios por todo el
mundo sin embargo todo eso es hoy en día
agua pasada para que os hagáis una idea
en la década de los años 90 italia
creció un 38% en los últimos 10 años tan
solo ha crecido el 2,5 por ciento a todo
esto hay que sumarle la deuda pública
italia es la quinta economía más
endeudada del mundo
para que os hagáis una idea la deuda
italiana supone casi el doble de todo el
pib de un país como brasil y da igual el
ranking que miremos italia es algo así
como el anti suecia es decir cuando
miramos un ranking de cualquier cosa
relacionada con economía educación o
cualquier otro baremo suecia suele ser
el país que está vamos a decirlo así en
la zona buena pues bien en cualquiera de
estos rankings y tal es un estar en el
otro extremo
[Música]
todo esto era la situación antes de la
pandemia y como ya os podéis imaginar
después de la pandemia la situación es
mucho peor
italia fue uno de los primeros países en
reportar casos de coronavirus fuera de
china y también ha sido uno de los
países más afectados pero esperad un
momento porque en italia los problemas
nunca vienen solos
[Música]
la recuperación de italia tras la
pandemia en peligro por la crisis
política y diréis pero aquí crisis
política se refiere esta noticia lo
cierto es que lo que en el resto del
mundo llamamos crisis política en italia
lo llaman jueves por la tarde si amigos
de visual político si la economía
italiana es un desastre se debe en buena
medida a sus políticos pocos países
tienen una política tan esquizofrénica
comunitaria os doy un ejemplo lo normal
en cualquier democracia es que un
candidato gana las elecciones y gobierna
durante cuatro o cinco años verdad sí
vale puede haber mociones de censura o
elecciones anticipadas pero eso no es lo
normal
italia es lo contrario es casi imposible
nombrar un primer ministro italiano que
haya terminado su mandato para que os
hagáis una idea la media de un gobierno
en italia es de 2 años sólo en la última
década los italianos han tenido siete
primeros ministros distintos habéis oído
bien ser político italiano es un trabajo
estresante pero tranquilos porque no
faltan puestos de trabajo pocos países
tienen más políticos que italia para que
os hagáis una idea si sumamos los
miembros del parlamento y el senado
italiano tenemos 951 parlamentario
italia tiene más parlamentarios que eeuu
o la unión europea sin embargo en el
vídeo de hoy vamos a centrarnos en un
político italiano muy concreto y diréis
de quién estoy hablando pues presentó a
supermán mario draghi y jura como primer
ministro de un gobierno de unidad en
italia noticias de febrero del 2021
así es italia tiene sorpresa un nuevo
primer ministro pero no se trata de un
político cualquiera hablamos de mario
draghi si habéis este vídeo desde
cualquier rincón de europa seguro que
tenéis un autógrafo de este señor en el
bolsillo porque si hablamos del ex
presidente del banco central europeo el
hombre al que todos en esta piel de toro
conocemos con el nombre de supermario y
diréis porque le llamamos supermario
pues porque se rumorea que tiene
superpoderes y diréis en serio qué clase
de superpoderes pues tiene el súper
poder de la palabra atentos a esta frase
wind in your man that we de normandie
disímil is ready to do what ever it
takes to pressure de jour
en bilín y termina
[Aplausos]
[Música]
días más tarde decir esta frase europa a
cabo con toda la crisis de la deuda así
sin más por supuesto que todo esto tiene
una explicación económica mucho más
compleja de la que hablaremos en otro
vídeo pero ahí queda la figura
legendaria la leyenda del hombre cuya
palabra sirvió para salvar el libro y la
pregunta ahora es de supermario salvar a
italia de sus políticos con una sola
frase como puede dictar ya salir de la
crisis hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
los años de su pero antes de seguir creo
que ya sé lo que se estaría preguntando
todos
fonseca de dónde ha sacado esa camiseta
tan maravillosa pues y esto es justo lo
que creéis que es merchandising
exclusivo de visual político y digo
exclusivo de verdad
hablamos de tazas y camisetas con
diseños originales creados por nosotros
mismos y diréis dónde lo podemos comprar
pues en algún sitio lo cierto es que
hemos decidido que el merchandising de
visual político nunca va a estar a la
venta sólo hay una forma de conseguirlo
y es apoyándonos en pasión si escribís
al nivel 3 de nuestro patrón os
enviaremos el merchandising a vuestra
casa tal cual como lois esto se explica
porque queremos que nuestro
merchandising esté reservado sólo para
los auténticos fans de visual político
así que si os unís a nuestro patrón de
nivel 3
no solamente vais a recibir nuestra
newsletter semanal con noticias y
análisis que no encontraréis en ningún
otro lugar sino que también recibiréis
nuestro merchandising exclusivo pero
ahora sigamos con nuestra historia los
que tengáis una edad ya os acordaréis de
esa época de oro de la música italiana
el momento en el que superó tanta va con
el primer kurt y laura pausini sonaban
las radios y todos llevábamos fotos de
desarrollo a salerno en nuestra carpeta
de clases
[Música]
bueno yo no hice eso pero seguro que un
amigo mío lo hizo
esa era la época dorada de italia los
talentos eran tan ricos como los
franceses y los alemanes de hecho en
aquel momento estaban invirtiendo en
europa del este y como si no hubiera
mañana es más ciudades como praga tienen
montones de edificios incluso barrios
enteros que son prácticamente en su
totalidad propiedad de italianos pero
eso es otra historia para otro vídeo la
pregunta es porque italia era tan rica
pues veréis hay muchas razones que lo
explican pero principalmente toda esa
prosperidad e italia se debía a esto
atentos a esta gráfica
aquí veis la cotización de la divisa
italiana antes del euro la llamada liga
italiana contra el dólar estadounidense
como veis la liga italiana era una
moneda muy débil y todo esto que
significa pues que estaba devaluándose
continuamente por ejemplo en 1936 un
dólar valía 850 libras 14 años más tarde
superaba las 2000 y diréis y todo esto
en qué medida afecta al crecimiento pues
os lo voy a explicar con un ejemplo
imaginado un fabricante de ropa italiano
que vende en eeuu si la lira se devalúa
el fabricante recibe más ligas por la
misma cantidad en dólares gracias a esto
puede bajar el precio en dólares y ser
más competitivo
normalmente devaluar la divisa aumenta
las exportaciones de un país ojo en el
corto plazo y diréis cuál es la parte
mala de devaluar pues que en el largo
plazo es el mismo fabricante de ropa no
tiene incentivos para invertir por
ejemplo cualquier máquina que compre en
el extranjero le va a salir mucho más
cara que a sus competidores
y diréis cuál es la conclusión de todo
esto pues que italia se convirtió en la
china de europa desde los años 70 hasta
los 90 italia llenaba los mercados
mundiales con productos de bajo coste es
decir hacían lo mismo pero más barato y
cuál es el problema de todo esto pues
que es fácil ser la china de europa
cuando china todavía no está en el
mercado internacional pero todo esto
cambio en el año 2001
[Música]
china es parte de la oms como os podéis
imaginar si tu principal ventaja
competitiva es el precio
buena suerte compitiendo con los
salarios bajos de china de un día para
otro todas esas baratijas made in italy
tuvieron que competir con las baratijas
made in china y diréis que podían hacer
en ese momento volver a devaluar la liga
pues no no podían hacerlo y porque no
podían pues por esto yo usaba se comen
carnes y de agua maní
y así es como le entrará en el euro
italia perdió todas sus ventajas
competitivas desde entonces este país no
ha vuelto a levantar cabeza y diréis
entonces la respuesta es obvia deberían
salirse del euro tal vez la pregunta
sería es posible que italia sea
competitiva sin tener que manipular
artificialmente su divisa por ejemplo
porque italia no innova os voy a dar un
dato inversión en imax de europa
invierte de media a 12 13% del pib en i
+ de italia sólo un 1 29% es más da
igual el ranking de educación que
miramos italia siempre es el país peor
parado de europa dicho de otra forma
para los que veáis este vídeo desde eeuu
italia es algo así como el missouri de
europa y diréis per dónde está el
problema porque están tan atrasados pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el país de la burocracia hay dos
profesiones que abundan editaría
políticos y funcionarios y no creáis que
hablamos de funcionarios cualquiera
según el fmi los funcionarios italianos
cobran un 20% más que sus homólogos en
la empresa privada
de hecho ganan prácticamente lo mismo
que los funcionarios alemanes aunque
alemania sea un país mucho más rico que
italia y es prácticamente imposible
despedirlos por supuesto si veis este
vídeo desde españa diréis anda pues
igualito que aquí pero si veis este
vídeo desde cualquier otra parte del
mundo diréis en serio pero qué locura
los privilegios de los funcionarios
llegan a tal punto que incluso ahora
tras el coronavirus muchos italianos
empiezan a protestar contra ellos los
italianos apuntan a la burguesía
burocrática y diréis pero de verdad esa
es la razón de todos los problemas de
italia que los funcionarios cobran mucho
y no se les puede despedir pues no
realmente ese no es el peor problema el
peor problema es que al tener esos
contactos tan blindados los funcionarios
italianos son completamente ineficientes
italia se hunde en el pozo de la falta
de competitividad a los que veis este
vídeo desde españa bueno pues que os voy
a decir
pero por ejemplo imaginad que tenemos
una empresa en dinamarca y tenemos que
demandar a un cliente que no paga lo que
debe pues bien en una media de poco
menos de un año el juzgado habrá
resuelto el caso en italia
ese mismo trámite tardaría la friolera
de tres años es más da igual el
procedimiento todo en italia lleva dos o
tres veces más que en cualquier otro
país europeo desde pagar impuestos hasta
crear una empresa a los que veis este
vídeo desde españa os diré quitaría está
incluso peor pero esperad un momento
porque el problema no se queda en que la
burocracia sea ineficiente el problema
de italia es que la burocracia está en
todas partes y aquí os vamos a dar un
ejemplo que vivimos en el propio equipo
de visual política hace unos años
veréis durante un tiempo tuvimos a una
chica italiana en el equipo que
trabajaba como guionista
esta chica quería poder trabajar también
con los grandes periódicos italianos
estilo y corriere de la sera' o
liberación el problema pues el problema
es que para poder ejercer como
periodista en italia
necesitas un permiso tal cual como louis
para ejercer de periodista en italia
necesitas conseguir tu licencia de
periodista y para eso necesitas
acreditar experiencia laboral como
periodista pues bien por mucho que la
firmáramos toda clase de documentos
diciendo que había trabajado en visual
político las autoridades italianas no se
le reconocieron a fin de cuentas youtube
desde cuando youtube puede considerarse
un medio de comunicación para que os
hagáis una idea existe todo un
reglamento para todos los pasos que
tienes que cumplir para abrir un medio
de comunicación y por si algunos lo
están planteando no italiano es famosa
precisamente por tener unos medios de
comunicación que sean referentes
internacionales más bien todo lo
contrario
no hay forma
conclusión unitaria es muy difícil
montar una pequeña empresa innovar y
crecer la burocracia se ha convertido en
un muro invisible que hace que muchos
negocios terminen en la economía
sumergida
[Música]
mientras alemania tiene las llamadas
mittelstand es decir medianas empresas
que son líderes mundiales en su nicho el
sector productivo de italia se divide en
dos grupos grandes empresas como el
grupo fiat o la energética eni que cada
vez son menos competitivas y micropymes
familiares en el otro que nunca fueron
competitivas dicho de otra forma italia
lleva décadas en caída libre y el
coronavirus ha sido el último clavo en
el ataúd la pregunta ahora es qué pueden
hacer para empezar a crecer de verdad
mario draghi también conocido como super
mario puede cambiar las cosas pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
plan marshall volvamos con nuestro
principal personaje de hoy super mario
fue presidente del banco central europeo
del año 2012 a 2019 y su legado más
importante fue salvar al euro gracias a
esas palabras mágicas que pronunció un
día bueno y también a la compra masiva
de deuda soberana y la inyección de
liquidez a los bancos pero todos le
recordaremos por aquella frase que
cambió las finanzas europeas de un día
para otro pues bien sus nuevas palabras
mágicas son las siguientes
[Música]
tenemos que reconstruir como después de
la guerra mario draghi y diréis pero qué
significan exactamente estas palabras
pues muy simple tras la segunda guerra
mundial eeuu envió ingentes cantidades
de dinero a italia para que se
reconstruyera a todo esto es le llamó el
plan marshall y no solamente afectó a
italia también al resto de países
europeos y por eso la primera prioridad
de supermario es qué hacemos con este
dinero pues además parlamento italiano
aprobó plan de recuperación de draghi y
os preguntaréis pero en qué consiste
este plan pues hablamos de nada menos
que 222 mil 100 millones de euros es
decir el 13 por ciento del pib italiano
casi todo este dinero se va a utilizar
para construir infraestructuras
principalmente en el sur de italia que
es más pobre es decir hablamos de
modernización de ferrocarriles
carreteras etcétera pero no sólo eso a
estas alturas ya nos hemos dado cuenta
de que el problema de italia no es que
tenga trenes viejos el problema de
italia es el tamaño y el funcionamiento
de su estado y por eso mario draghi ha
sido innovador en algo quiere despedir a
casi la tercera parte de sus colegas
atentos
[Música]
italia aprueba en referéndum recortar
345 congresistas puede que esto os
parezca una medida populista es más
tampoco podemos decir que este recorte
sea una medida de draghi en realidad se
empezó a debatir antes incluso de que
supermario llegara al poder pero lo
cierto es que italia tiene más diputados
y senadores que prácticamente cualquier
otro país sólo le supera reino unido y
china para que os hagáis una idea españa
con 50 millones de habitantes tiene un
parlamento de 350 diputados
italia con sólo 60 millones de
habitantes es decir 10 millones más
tiene un parlamento de 630 diputados
y os hagáis una idea esta reducción de
diputados supondrá un ahorro de mil
millones de euros en diez años pero esta
medida va mucho más allá del dinero tal
vez ahora sea más fácil conseguir
consensos puede que esto le permita
hablar y acabar su mandato pensad que
hablamos de italia lo que en cualquier
otro país llamaríamos una crisis
política o un impeachment en italia lo
llaman jueves por la tarde claramente
necesitan cambiar algo en su estructura
político
la pregunta es es esta mejor forma de
hacerlo pues lo cierto es que solo el
tiempo lo dirá lo que sí podemos decir
es que el plan de draghi no se limita
aquí también quiere bajar los impuestos
y sobre todo reducir la burocracia el
plan italiano también busca una
modernización de la administración
pública que incluye reducir los tiempos
de los juicios civiles en 40% y en 25%
de los juicios penales además quiere
impulsar la competencia y acabar con las
prácticas monopolísticas de las grandes
empresas italianas también habrá muchos
recortes en la burocracia pero por el
momento es pronto para saber exactamente
cómo se va a materializar toda esta
agenda
por el momento solo podemos decir que la
magia de supermario está empezando a
funcionar con draghi la campaña de
vacunación se ha acelerado es más
esperan tener el 80% de la población
vacunada en septiembre de supermario ya
ha cumplido sus 100 primeros días con
una aprobación de más del 50% sin
embargo todavía queda la parte más dura
de su mandato porque si pensáis que
recortar burocracia en un país con
millones de funcionarios acomodados no
va a traer protestas es que no conocéis
a los italianos así que ahora turno para
vosotros queréis que mario draghi
conseguirá acabar con la burocracia
italiana o tal vez la burocracia
italiana terminará acabando con 'super
mario' y con su leyenda fue de italia
salir de sus dos décadas de crisis
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
quien visual politics sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]